negli episodi precedenti di residenti vo
avrò detto è morta tipo 62 volte durante
la ed è morta solo adesso quello che hai
tra le mani che male c'è
queste grosso
ah ecco la salve eccoti qua
l'altro pezzo deve demi figlia
immaginavo che succederebbe
penso alle paroline da dirti cosa no
però come la mia però che se questa a
queste critiche ha fatto un manichino di
di sua madre quella che vedevo negli né
in i ritratti quando ce n'è neanche uno
scusate un attimo non capito allenare mi
sono sparite è sparito tutto
l'inventario allora ragazzi provera che
devo devo smontare la bambola per certi
leggono gioco e ci sono i lego solo un
po più
l'ac arezzo proprio che fa i tacchi
pezzi bravo questa chiave d'argento che
senso ha
che bello minchia mi piace un sacco
giocare a sta roba bambola
no credo che sia tua mamma mia e sua
moglie
qui hai fatto una bambola di sua moglie
state che cosa macabra ma è una specie
di di escape room dove devo smontare la
bambola di mia moglie jack cestaro
spiega che è successo che perché sento
passi chi è che si muove c'è un pezzo in
ogni in ogni posto c'è un plesso 9
fichissimo bellissimo in realtà i
ragazzi se avete visto del parente
semplicemente andata nel 15 mila
trasforma del manichino e solo così è
successo questo come ragazzi svitto
pezzi di mia moglie simulator è
diventato il nuovo residenti volo quindi
niente male
bello quindi mi manca qualcosa per
aprirle band e poi anche l'altro braccio
ok all anello l'anello ma questa non è
cioè nel senso non hanno preso veramente
l'europa è stacca l'anello non hanno
preso veramente le cose di mia moglie
spero anello coperto di sangue va bene
la famiglia era un attimo allora nello
ma vi posso combinare no questo lo
pulisco sicuramente le forbici mi
servono per tagliarle band è che non so
bene dove sono
qua c'è la stanza e si apre con la
chiave fin qua e fino qua è uno schifo
ragazzi bellissimo al lavandino posso
usufruire l'anello che pirla anello non
ho annunciato la serva sta roba per ora
solo riciclo
lo uso per un'altra tip ha visto che è
morta riportiamo di nuovo i veri tirchi
rimorchiano con i regali delle ddd altri
che ha aperto la porta cd un'opportunità
aperta però io sento cosi sto gioco sono
pazzo va bene allora ho preso tutto lì
ma io lo devo dimettere non ho capito no
non glielo dovevamo che meno male che
c'è tanto non si capisce niente di
quanto c'è di sé forbici per favore
qualsiasi dovunque siano si potrebbe
inserire qualcosa c'era nel
nell'occhio cioè quella roba lì però
prima devo trovare forbici sicuro io lo
so io io io lo sapevo lo sapevo che
c'era il codice dentro lo sapevo 005 29
11 va bene lo sapevo che c'era un po
diceva ma ci sarei giocare le palle 05
29 11 camon devo cercare in casa le
altre cose quindi va bene gli ex almeno
ne cerco in casa perché adesso ci
saranno cose sparsi in giro che prima
non c'erano giustamente mi devo
aspettare tipo jumps che certe cose
quali trovo easy o c'è qualcuno che nel
mentre vi segue vabbè allora sentite
capiamoci subito che cambiamo gioco
tornò a si apre anche di là aver bisogno
di forbici alla fine niente di che ci
pensa potevo anche taglia poteva anche
di strapparle le bende sono il rischio
la morte guardia le forbici però va bene
che cosa ci sto a fare qua dentro sesto
posto
guarda che comunque ragazzi hanno messo
hanno messo talmente tanti cosi
cos'è che ci fa qui per il cazzo ne sono
ma che cos'è chiave di carica che ho
preso scelta avete troppa fiducia nella
mia persona e vi ringrazio ma è mal
riposta sta per giungere ad ora questo è
così sicuro questo ma ragazzi ma che ne
so io
minchia ha forse così sai mai giusto
così e giusto perché non lo so non so se
l'ha fatto giusto ho fatto giusto o
falso giusto al primo tentativo tra
l'altro genio un genio non sono anche
come non mi chiedete perché non ho idea
vabbè tutto sto bordello per trovare per
trovare una pinzetta c'è figura di con
cui posso tirare fuori dalla foto dalla
bocca di mia
ok
meno male non si chiude st porti che
volevo andare via io vabbè ma niente c'è
qualcos'altro che devo trovare vero c'è
una pellicola ok
vado a prendere la pellicola che sta
nella bocca di mia moglie e la metto nel
proiettore così ci godiamo un film tutti
insieme che mi sembra la cosa più bella
almeno che non c'è ok a meno che non ci
sia un jobs che stavo dicendo però è
cascato il quadro aumento e stavo
dicendo sta cosa tra l'altro tempismo
incredibile e va bene va dai ragazzi
allora bocca qua faccio il dentista
ormai è mai visto lavoro potevo
prenderlo anche con le dita solo che
sono schizzinose realtà viva beh
pellicola che succede a radio tutto
normale vero che lo sterno ma mia moglie
è morta la ancora possibile sta roba
ma non è che ancora viva e non ho capito
e moglie è morta e quindi noi ragazzi
polsi tutto questo non ha senso
salve devo andare proprio dove c'è lei
dove sta lei guarda che sfiga e tra
l'altro non sbatte la porta sicuro 3 2 1
non è soprattutto che culo fa meno male
per una volta che dico una cosa non
succede
novaro che sa cosa possa provare le
varie mette a pellicola vediamo sto film
kick it la3 la3 no in grande devo
mettere in ordine di cose
la nostra famiglia la vostra famiglia
dice il miglior amico di rose rosa ad
ora questa favola la cosa più importante
la nostra vita che è lì un regalo di
nozze della nonna e la prova dell'amore
eterno di ethan hawke è il regalo di
nozze della norma sta qua la favola
erosi in mezzo vari yes yes
papà luca nei bei e forse non dovevo
dirlo sta cosa perché adesso minchia the
ring ci manca solo quello tanto facciamo
so che lo so aver tanto manca solo
quello una culla vuota va bene nicchia
ragazza che ansia
cos'è bravo buttati di testa nel top del
pozzo bello se scassato pure ansie tv
con occhio tutto sto casino per scassare
il ei kim in the shadow qua qualcuno ha
aperto la pro visto l'ho visto che ha
aperto la porta bio vive l'inutile
infatti finta di niente teste di culo
no ragazzi ne parla e bambole dentro i
muri no e ci sono signori signorile fort
tutto sto bordello per tra le forbici 46
qua sotto c'è qualcosa che le bende sono
proposte a ok ok ok ok tagliare le
forbici perfetto lo puoi fare anche con
le mani ma se i figli roma ti capisco ti
capisco cosa c'è di qua questa è una
stanza ha detto che non l'avevo vista
prima rondi diga ma fa dei korn ha fatto
i cornetti tori mia di che stai parlando
mai visto veramente parlando con mia
moglie morta successo noi non sto
capendo raga mia moglie è morta come è
possibile
me lo sto immaginando c'è una porta
strana che non sa ci vuole ci vuole un
neonato da ficcare nella porta per far
aprire che va bene e questa quale altra
porta quella dell'altro lato che è
perfetto fino a qua c'ero arrivato anche
io
ora con le forbici taglio ok taglio
porca [ __ ] che sono studiate bene
queste almeno almeno essere sinceri con
le forbici taglio qua che non è proprio
una cosa ortodossa la fa prendiamo
qualsiasi ma dai ma cosa ci voleva a
toglierlo con le mani ceramica va bene
che io so frigo roma tutti io stai messo
peggio diga
mi dica se nelle mia figlia cosa parma
allora ragazzi forniamo solo al volo per
la porta la giunta abbiamo tutto allora
il corvo e quello rivolto verso destra
gli occhi chiusi e questo cose qua
quindi ci siamo
il corpo rivolto rivolto verso destra
gli occhi chiusi
quindi il corvo è questo qua e adesso ci
dovremmo essere let's go
yes forza nuova per ragazzi fa cosa no
mica se mi spunta la curva me ne vado
non ragazzi ori questa questa che questa
cosa orribile
porca vacca che brutto che è frutto che
bruttissima scalinata orribile proprio
dove ci sarà video ok
meno male che tutto è tutto dimenticato
che comunque in casa una roba del genere
voglio capire cosa serve perché non
serve a niente
ok non sono ragazzi non ho capito che io
stia andando cioè secondo me come spunto
in duomo tra un po a milano chiave del
quadro elettrico a c'è una bambola
distro chiave del quadro elettrico che
per l'ascensore posso uscire adesso c'è
qualcuno che spacca qualcosa
sì sicuramente sicuramente proprio e
proprio mia figlia chi è che fa sto
casino maledizione già che non sto a
casa già che non c'è mia figlia che
piange almeno non fatevela piangere
anche quando non ce l'ho madonna tutto
buio quel successo
no questa radio che è sparita la bambola
c'è nel sangue comunque diga
andate a cagare tanto si sente ovunque
vado milillo penati storico si si non ho
capito cosa sto facendo
salve cidob lo zio tantissimo ma chi è
che vada si sta qua guarda mai e non
capisco non capisco non ho capito cosa
faccio il giro opposto faccio un giro
posto cosa diro posto c'era un ameba
sfera una era quello che piangeva
madonna che brutto
faccio un giro al contrario minchia che
brutta cosa ha visto raga ok fino a
quando tutto ok
il quadro elettrico sta qua fuori dai
dai dai veloce veloce la [ __ ] la chiave
si guarda bene ok ciao chiavi a è lo
sblocca sicuro come non c'è corrente
anno ok qui a rilievo del bambino che
vai io penso di dover riattivare la
corrente mi chiamo si vede nulla raga no
mica sta proprio qua rega e io devo
andare esattamente dove sei tu e quello
il problema
faccio un altro giro
è
ma francesca è stata lei che ha posto è
più o meno questo spostati più veloce
però
se n'è andata a madonna ragazzo è stato
orribile cia bambola però io devo
veramente prende una pastiglia che posso
farlo
madonna c'era la bambola vi nell'angolo
lobbista madonna legami se mi sembra pt
st parte stato orribile
vabbè è tutto tranquillo sangue l'ho
proprio più comunque non ancora armi né
niente però va bene siamo arrivati nella
camera da letto il tutto sto casino sono
anche come fusibile certo grazie
posso guardare potevo lasciarlo dentro
vino che no santo iddio devo tornare al
quadro elettrico ad un casino sto
facendo non avete idea sotto casino per
uscire perché no porca [ __ ] porca [ __ ]
via via via via via posto a cosa porta
cosa non c entra in rapporto si
non ci passi teoricamente 24 che è
arrivata come è possibile tutto questo
dove vado non posso andare sue parti ci
ho vestito momento doveva dove come
faccio a ministro va detto meno ma ho
usato il primo armadietto del gioco c'è
il primo che serve attendiamo almeno fa
versetti simpatici non si vede niente
raga
spero che non avrà la forza economica
per la porta mi butta fuori scommettete
sicuro sicuro
minchia ragazze ansia ma se esco adesso
tipo no se come devo aspettare ma che
secondo me mi scaraventa fuori sicuro mi
vede mi vede 100 100 non mi ha visto gli
ha fuori dalle palle di 20 ragazzi ma
stasta parte comunque veramente
ansiolitico e non c'è non hai armi non
posso fare niente
quando non ti puoi difendere in un gioco
horror veramente e la morte
si no giovanni mi chiamo così dai
cantieri accessori qua non so dove sia
finita tra l'altro impossibile non c'è
più schiaccia il tasto e non lo
schiaccia non lo schiaccia io l'ho
schiacciato veloce veloce veloce e
veloce veloce veloce è aperto sia
apertosi apertosi aperto che li divide
ma fai schifo
mammamia orribile che è una melma ma
cos'è hanno messo la voce del bambino in
una poltiglia vabbè se però quel pokemon
lì come schiava quello che tipo sembra
una mail ma perde è un po come la fiera
no no basta ho fatto un giro in clip
basta per favore
c'è la bambina la devo far fuori ancora
perché devo prendere il pezzo di mia
figlia
il problema è che già ci ho messo due
ore
mettilo un po di bambole in giro con ti
capita la palla per terra
ecco sì comandi si limita la shoah
vabbé vabbé conviene trovarli
precampionato e gli amici ti chiama e io
continuo a marzo ma domanda io devo
trovare senza armi come cazzola trovo se
trovo lei prima che mi ammazzino vinto
io a nascondino e tipo e tipo nascondino
2.0 va bene non ho idea di dove possa
essere
eccola l'ho trovata subito però la
prossima mi ha morso e tanto che cazzo
mi manca già subita o non le ha fatto
lievitare
quindi io devo continuare a trovare la
prima che mi ammazzino le altre bambole
va bene non ho capito cosa devo fare
devo sentire secondo me devo sentire con
l'audio dove dove ride o poi ci sono le
macchie di sangue fra quello
dragano note ma non è impossibile da
provare è veramente il casinò segue le
macchie di sangue sego l'audio non ho
capito le macchie ma in trovando se lo è
se impazziscono prima che la prego qua
se impazziscono prima che la trovi
gratuite
sarà stata si riparte che morta quindi
ragazzi a una certa iniziano a tremare
tutte le bambole quando succede questa
cosa non so che c'è se non la trovi in
tempo non siano ammessi se non la trovi
il tempo non so cosa succede che lo
stato si assomiglia dubito che sia
finita
sono stato bravo e non trovate subito
l'ho uccisa io non ci ho vinto o finita
non sono partire una volta fantastico la
prima volta che succede in un gioco in
dieci anni di youtube risolve 8 non ci
credo è stato bravissimo ragazzo la
porto sta chiave ho trovato il pezzo di
mia cieli di virare via da qui vai vai
previsto cosa che cazzo state sta roba
combinata con la chiara 4 è la chiave
del free to free tocca la sua ricerca
ragazzi l'ho battuto subito sono stato
bravissimo
ciao bambolina trofeo ragazzi sono stato
bravissimo e mi sono preso la bambola da
certo perché non dovrei prende una
bambola indemoniata perché non dovrei
portare annabelle in casa mia
madonna ragazzino stato sono troppo
contento che l'ho battuta subito non ci
avrei scommesso un euro su me stesso di
ste cose che ti giuro che non mi succede
mai una cosa del genere sono stato
bravissimo va bene basta out elogiarmi
andiamo là ora guys è il momento di
arrivare al alla porta col feto a
quattro ali
minchia che poi dall'altro mi sa che tu
puoi decidere da chi andare cioè i vari
boss di paul e credo non lo so quali
sono una e la dama limitless kulala milf
in bianco poi c'è benevento
poi c'è mormorò che acquistando
lui sostanzialmente va bene allora siamo
tornati nel villaggio di tutto sto
casino ma se riesco a prendere molto
bene vediamo se me la prendo nel culo
tempo zero
berna secondo me questo buona merda
costate tanto l'ho preso degli schiavi
entra julio chiudere con la porta di
cosenza merda non so dove devo andare
ragazzi maturi stop
non so cosa devo fare l'olio lo meno
cielo gli sparo o scatto che faccio ti
sparo proprio dove la minchia gere
apribile madonna
devo stare attento che non mi prenda
perché gira per il villaggio è
divertente
allora stefano nel sito facciamo le cose
le mie ferite sono gravi non mi le sei
morto se riuscissi ad arrivare al
vecchio mulino potrei fermarlo a devo
arrivare al vecchio mulino raga non so
dove sia a mulino ad acqua eccolo qua mi
piace vada avanti che pirla
ce l'avevo veramente davanti ok perché
potrei fermarlo minchia prevista porta
veloce cos'è che c'è qua dentro
questo ciclo dentro c'è qualcosa qua
dentro la rassicurava sedi esplosiva
eccolo qua c'è l'arma potremmo di senso
si eccolo qua
minchia con lanciagranate mi questo
questo me lo tengo fuga scrive lodo
allora lanciagranate provò a sparargli e
che ciò troppi pochi colpi secondo me i
ragazzi con me non lo faccio fuori ce ne
vogliono di più chissà cosa ti dà se lo
fai fuori non devo sprecare neanche uno
vieni quasi o morto non è morto è morto
note morto è morto è morto ci ho fatto
bestia cristallizzata mi chiamano male
c'è qualcun altro via via via via fuori
dalle balle
così sembra che si possa rompere e come
me sono rock con la bomba ma i granata
libero non posso più tirargli lance non
posso più lanciati dai granata erano
finite per quello là però posso
annunciarti una bomba artigianale questo
nice
meno male perché non avevo idea di come
rom per stappare va bene bene be nice
sono riusciti a far fuori coloni sono
troppo contento perché chissà quanto
vale sta a fare perché ciò devo tornare
a luca però perché giocando un ottima
iaria far fuori ed io non ce l'ha fatta
allora non ne ho tante di bombe te lo
dico mezzo rimaste due quindi benino fa
cacate ok dai manca il pezzo a nolo che
ci curiosi e l'unico gioco horror dove
puoi arrivare effettivamente un appiglio
meno male ci sono i maiali ragazzi
dispiace video seccare tutti che mi
servono le cose ok carne dov'è andato
l'altro c'erano
così si sopporta la foto di un animale
raro grazie genoa guarda il gioco ma è
cambiata da così a così air è solamente
un altro gioco ascensore del lago
artificiale censore va bene fatto salvo
che non ho capito che quello che ci
stiamo andando regalando così è il suo
posto qui ascensore del lago d'iseo
tanto sul coltello in mano come se
potesse aiutarmi a fare qualcosa un
coltello ok c'è un ascensore ragalo non
so dove dormono intenditori di porta va
bene l'ultima volta che tirate una
maniglia così ho perso la mano e stato
molto divertente quel momento nino
telescopi dell'incredibile non vedo
realizzarlo ragazzi
ok che schifo la melma ci passo
mica ci sono passato non sono che come
si certo certo
allunga proprio la mano ecco chi vive
qua e lui gobbo di notre dame dillo non
avevo capito
baila impresa o chiarimento ci pensi se
ne vado delle batterie
e no andrei novità ce fa niente milan
per voi farei qualunque cosa ti posso
fargli le scarpe nuove
questo qui lo prendo io la bimba
speciale di miranda cosa vuoi fare
e mia figlia non è sua figlia è mai
questa ciò è contrario che sia il body
mentali miranda miranda rivoli sua
figlia basta stronzate ti prego insieme
la ruby gli altri rideranno sono morti
gli altri ma una normetta me ne frega ti
prego sei stupido e parli troppo ragazzi
e la cosa mi abbiano rapito la mia
l'interno a me lui che evoca le mail
io non ti farò per scappare e quindi mai
poi spesso dagli episodi oggi di
residence e mancano ancora pochi episodi
per il finale ma aspettatevi veramente
di tutto vi ringrazio per aver seguito
la serie fino adesso vi ringrazio per
aver subito il video ha lasciato un bel
mi piace un commento è noi come sempre
ci vediamo domani
un bacino pubblica beh ragazzi